[Music]
in mythological ancient Greece soaring
above Crete on wings made from wax and
feathers
Icarus the son of Daedalus defied the
laws of both man and nature ignoring the
warnings of his father he rose higher
and higher to witnesses on the ground he
looked like a god and as he peered down
from above he felt like one too but in
mythological ancient Greece the line
that separated God from man was absolute
and the punishment for mortals who
attempted to cross it was severe such
was the case for Icarus and Daedalus
years before Icarus was born his father
Daedalus was highly regarded as a genius
inventor craftsman and sculptor in his
homeland of Athens he invented carpentry
and all the tools used for it he
designed the first bathhouse and the
first dance floor he made sculptures so
lifelike
that Hercules mistook them for actual
men
though skilled and celebrated Daedalus
was egotistical and jealous worried that
his nephew was a more skillful craftsman
Daedalus murdered him as punishment
Daedalus was banished from Athens and
made his way to Crete preceded by his
storied reputation Daedalus was welcomed
with open arms by creats King Minos
their acting as the palace technical
advisor
Daedalus continued to push the
boundaries for the king's children he
made mechanically animated toys that
seemed alive he invented the ships sail
and mast which gave humans control over
the wind with every creation
Daedalus challenged human limitations
that had so far kept mortals separate
from gods until finally he broke right
through King Minos his wife pacify had
been cursed by the god Poseidon to fall
in love with the Kings prized bull under
this spell she asked Daedalus
to help her seduce it with
characteristic audacity he agreed
Daedalus constructed a hollow wooden cow
so realistic that it fooled the bull
with pacify hiding inside Daedalus
creation she conceived and gave birth to
the half-human half bull Minotaur
this of course enraged the king who
blamed Daedalus for enabling such a
horrible perversion of natural law as
punishment Daedalus was forced to
construct an inescapable labyrinth
beneath the palace for the Minotaur when
it was finished
Minos then imprisoned Daedalus and his
only son Icarus within the top of the
tallest tower on the island where they
were to remain for the rest of their
lives
but Daedalus was still a genius inventor
while observing the birds that circled
his prison the means for escape became
clear he and Icarus would fly away from
their prison as only birds or gods could
do using feathers from the flocks that
perched on the tower and the wax from
candy
Daedalus constructed two pairs of giant
wings as he strapped the wings to his
son Icarus
he gave a warning flying too near the
ocean would dampen the wings and make
them too heavy to use flying too near
the Sun the heat would melt the wax and
the wings would disintegrate in either
case they surely would die therefore the
key to their escape would be in keeping
to the middle
with the instructions clear both men
left from the tower they were the first
mortals ever to fly while Daedalus
stayed carefully to the midway course
Icarus was overwhelmed with the ecstasy
of flight and overcome with the feeling
of divine power that came with it
Daedalus could only watch in horror as
Icarus ascended higher and higher
powerless to change his son's dire fate
when the heat from the Sun melted the
wax on his wings
Icarus fell from the sky just as
Daedalus had many times ignored the
consequences of defying the natural laws
of mortal men in the service of his ego
Icarus was also carried away by his own
hubris in the end both men paid for
their departure from the path of
moderation dearly Icarus with his life
and Daedalus with his regret
you
[Music]